welcome to this video playing spies
tonight spies tonight young you don't
yeah what I was trying to say is you
meet the players all the time that you
have absolutely never played before it's
always interesting never play them okay
trying an interesting new line here
against them rubenstein with 92 with c6
this looks a bit strange but it is
playable getting the bishop here and
then later play in the center the
question is d 6 or d5 can also play d 6
cm d 685 maybe maybe do that going from
somewhat a different type of setup than
usual I can also take now and play d5
okay
now I have a good day good development I
wonder can I do something aggressive
quickly nigeria nigeria might have to
where they have no key after work that's
never going to work okay so probably
just another developing move Bishop g5 I
can just go h6 and he will then need to
give up the bishop pal yes this one who
check
maybe night fh to e6 this idea all night
f a g6 oh that's a nice move well you
didn't see that coming but it makes a
good impression getting the brook maybe
into the game quickly could you okay to
this 96cm and it's a bit o surprising
that's a bit weakening the smooth that's
okay it also controls some important
square so maybe not to be condemned hmm
okay just make sure that p5 is not
coming coming easily came here b5 takes
takes takes here it's not not the
problem with the night being misplaced
I'd like to I'd like to get some some
lift former King here
b5 not really on takes a Bab rookie
2nite a to this even night c5 takes no
not not this there is no for con on c
383 yes I'll take it white reasons yeah
sometimes yeah the night only six this
is a bit unusually placed a feel so we
can give that up you can sometimes give
that up and sometimes just not to see it
yeah very very short game with this
blunder I still like to to upload the
game too to illustrate this idea with c
6 cm if you look for an opening line
against the 92 here c6 is quite
interesting Adam it's not the main 95 is
played mostly which is okay for black
there's also ruki aid which would be in
my book but c6 is also a funny move
because it really it frees this the
square on c7 and it's still very
flexible you can also after he did this
I also could have played d5 here with a
fairly in normal position later playing
he five if possible it's not to knock
been at all and this is also also a
possibility like it's a bit behind in
development but check sir it's a fairly
close position so you don't really have
any anything to fear because of that yet
so it's a nice own little line that you
can play without any bigger theoretical
effort to put into ok thanks for
watching